hi guys I'm currently in Germany I've  come on a course to learn about how to  improve my youtube videos and some of  the content was really funny and  interesting so I thought I'd share with  you  hi Samuel Leeds here I'm a property  investor an entrepreneur I don't want to  be other side as a video because that  would be silly I don't want to be  completely out of the video that would  also be saying and I also don't want a  lot of space above my head because it  makes me look less powerful and when in  fact I am a powerful person but if I do  this I look weak and vulnerable if I do  this I'm the two dominant if I do this I  look nice and relatable - but here a  little dominant - this is too close but  this is just the right distance baby  yeah the light is good but here  it's also good it's even good down here  so that's about as simple as it gets  now you know all you need to know to  make your own videos - and I look  forward to watching them  [Music]